Oh Rio known for its beaches bikinis and
utter inability to prepare for the 2016
Summer Olympics just how did the city
famous for hosting extravagant parties
become such a hot mess here are five
reasons why the Rio Olympics is already
a disaster Rio has been in some pretty
hot water for the extremely hazardous
levels of raw sewage and trash floating
in its disease-ridden waterways an
attempt to clean it up with eco barriers
failed after the water was found to have
bacteria 1.7 million times with
considered harmful on a beach in
Southern California some athletes like
the US Olympic rowing team have decided
to wear antimicrobial suits but health
experts say it won't be enough to
protect them from infection and if that
wasn't enough recent studies have found
antibiotic resistant super bacteria off
beaches and in the lagoon where Olympic
rowing canoeing and triathlon swimming
events are set to be held brazil is
broke and still Rio has spent millions
on the Olympics and taken out an eight
hundred and sixty million dollar loan
from the government to cover costs the
Olympics has been used as a
justification for projects like
million-dollar beachfront condos in a
subway expansion to a wealthy suburb but
not much is being done to help average
Brazilians thousands of families have
been evicted to make room for Olympic
Park in Rio and what some have termed a
social cleansing residents say they've
been intimidated by the government into
leaving without adequate notice and
offered less than market value for their
homes despite recent years of progress
violence and crime rates are back up in
Rio where nearly 2,000 people have been
murdered this year already
while violence is mostly concentrated in
the favelas an Australian athlete has
been mugged in a group of Spanish
sailors competing in the Olympics were
caught in the middle of a gunfight
and though some 85,000 police officers
and soldiers are to be deployed during
the games their paychecks have been
delayed leading some to threaten to quit
the city has also seen an increase in
police brutality more than 2,500 people
have been killed by the police in Rio
since the city won the Olympic bid in
2009 remember Dilma roussef Brazil's
president who was suspended in May after
being accused of illegally manipulating
the country's budget to hide a huge
deficit
well Rousseff's now facing impeachment
proceedings which hasn't exactly been
creating the festive mood everyone hoped
for this Olympics the verdict isn't
expected until after the game's end you
may have noticed that Zika didn't make
the list
that's because though the mosquito-borne
virus has been a concern all year it's
now winter in Brazil in risk of
infection during the Olympics is almost
zero
according to brazil's health minister
when all is said and done the Olympics
are fleeting it's the local Brazilians
we'll end up with all the dirty water
violence messy politics and a weaker
than ever economy